breaking overnight the u.s military is
bracing for another possible terror
attack during evacuation efforts in
afghanistan this comes after launching a
deadly drone airstrike near the border
with pakistan against what's described
as planner as a planner for isis k an
affiliate of the islamic state terror
group officials say the target was
killed without any additional loss of
life backing up president biden's
promise to hunt down those responsible
for thursday's suicide bombing at kabul
airport isis k claimed responsibility
for the blast that killed at least 170
people including 13 u.s service members
the u.s embassy in kabul has issued a
new warning to american citizens to
avoid kabul airport due to security
threats skyler henry is at the white
house with the latest skyler good
morning
hey dana good morning to you well there
are only three days left to evacuate the
remaining americans and afghan allies
before u.s troops fully withdraw from
afghanistan but president biden remains
steadfast in finishing the job despite
thursday's attack and those potential
threats by isis k
heart goes out our hearts go out to all
those who we've lost
in a meeting with israel's new prime
minister naftali bennett on friday
president biden said the mission in
afghanistan would continue
the mission there
being performed is dangerous
and it's
now
it's come with a significant loss of
american personnel but it's a worthy
mission because they continue to
evacuate
folks out of that region out of the
airport
the white house confirming around 4 200
more people were evacuated out of kabul
friday evening more than 109 000 already
out since august 14th
we're also learning more about the 13
service members killed in thursday's
blast
11 marines one army soldier and one navy
medic
max soviet of sandusky ohio on instagram
his sister wrote he was there to help
people and now he's gone and my family
will never be the same
and twenty-year-old marine riley
mccollum of wyoming he was just a baby
during the september 11th attacks now
mccollum's widow is due with their baby
in just a few weeks meanwhile president
biden is drawing criticism in washington
some republican lawmakers are calling
for the president to resign or be
impeached following thursday's attack
yesterday house minority leader kevin
mccarthy fell short of those calls but
said there would be a quote day of
reckoning for president biden i'm
extremely frustrated with this president
as i said if you want to be president of
the free world
you have to have the faith the trust and
the confidence of the american public
president biden lost that yesterday
toledo mccarthy's criticism the biden
administration says now isn't the time
for politics the president's national
security team says quote in all
likelihood another attack in kabul is
likely in that the next few days will be
the most dangerous period to date as u.s
forces look to draw down by that august
31st deadline jeff all right skyler
thank you